u.s defense officials say the last
remaining american and nato troops have
left the bagram military
base in afghanistan and handed it over
to afghan forces
bagram was the epicenter of the u.s and
nato's war against the taliban and
al-qaeda
at its peak 100 000 u.s troops were
stationed there
that 20-year mission is now coming to an
end
and a complete withdrawal of all foreign
forces from the country
is thought to be imminent
i'm joined now by dw's nato
correspondent in brussels
terry schultz terry uh on wednesday we
saw german troops already removing
their troops as part of that nato
contingent
they've now left afghanistan now the
main nato base in bagram is closing
it's all coming a little earlier than
expected though why is that
hi rebecca well bagram isn't actually
closing it's actually it's just being
handed over to
uh afghan forces 100 having been secured
by
nato and u.s forces all of these 20
years
so this is really a big step because
this is of course
uh um you know where where nato and and
us forces staged
a lot of their operations and it remains
to be seen whether the afghans can
keep bagram secured
now the air base in bagram was the main
airport for nato people to get its
people
in and out of the country now there's
not just military staff of course we're
talking about diplomats as well
what does this not closure as you say
but what does pulling out u.s and nato
troops from that air base
mean for the future and particularly
when it comes to security
this remains to be seen because there is
another airport the civilian airport
elsewhere in town and this too is
is primarily uh secured by afghan forces
but there have been talks now for quite
some time
with turkey that turkey would secure the
military side of that airport and that
would be a really important step
because then of course the u.s could
keep some equipment there
when their diplomats and and uh troops
fly in and out
you would have a little bit more
confidence in that side of the airport
but those talks have not concluded i
just checked this morning with sources
and it's really uh uncertain yet whether
that that agreement can be concluded
with turkey
now terry the security situation in
afghanistan is of course
uh unstable at the moment there are
fears of a civil war with the taliban
on the rise and warlords battling for
power
after being nearly 20 years in
afghanistan do nato troops
not have a certain responsibility to
stay and help
that's certainly an argument that has
been made and one that
that the u.s and uh and nato considered
uh it
once they made the decision basically
they came to the conclusion that
that this war was not one that they
could win that the taliban could not be
uh finally vanquished militarily uh
they really did rush to the exit um and
this uh moving up of the deadline of of
u.s troops to leave is something that we
had heard rumored
moving it up from september 11th which
was the official deadline
um but i i would not be surprised that
within the next couple of days
um by the fourth of july we hear that uh
all u.s troops uh are out of the country
that is quite a speed up terry tell us
what nato achieved in its 20 years in
afghanistan
the end chapter is not written yet but
signs do not look
good even u.s and nato
commanders confirmed that the taliban is
retaking territory even before the
pull-out was announced the taliban
controlled
half the country i mean i think that's a
statistic that would shock a lot of
people after 20 years of
u.s and nato forces there people on the
ground are very scared
uh it without without the u.s and nato
forces there
a lot of the security that had been
fragile but at least uh
somewhat intact will be gone and i think
nato would have a very hard time calling
this a success story
and we've seen the us dial back what
what it expected to achieve there to
saying
well we got osama bin laden and that's
what we were there for
all right dw correspondent terry schultz
in brussels brussels thank you very much
for that
you